der romancier jean knittel berühmt
berüchtigt
viele mythen ranken sich um seine person
es heißt scotland yard habe ihn gejagt
und knittel sei ein nazi sympathisant
gewesen
die germanistin erhöhen hat anfang der
80er jahre über kittels leben und werk
ihre dissertation verfasst bei den
recherchen stieß sie damals auf heftigen
widerstand
auch beim archiv wollte sie der
zuständige erst ab
doch der reihe nach
knittel wird 1891 in indien geboren
angeblich auf einer bahn station
fakt ist john ist der sohn eines
missionars er ist 3 als die familie nach
basel sieht john besuchte missionsschule
danach das gymnasium dort fliegt er raus
vermutlich weil der freigeist vor den
autoritäten nicht kuscht knittel zieht
nach london arbeitet bei einer bank dann
bei einer filmfirma wo er seinen
lebenslangen freund den schriftsteller
robert hitchens kennenlernen auch
knittel beginnt zu schreiben
mit erfolg heimlich heiratet er die
17-jährige frances die beiden fliehen
aus dem elternhaus auf ihren fersen
scotland yard so geht die sage
belegt ist dass knittel 1934 mit via
mala der durchbruch gelingt mit der
geschichte der familie laurenz die
unweit der schlucht im bündnerland ein
sägewerk betreibt vater jonas ein
despotischer trunkenbold tyrannisiert
die familie bis aufs blut
1961 verkörpert von gert fröbe mittels
inspirationsquelle die familie seiner
frau erhält korrespondenz prägt meter
mörderin im zuchthaus
das heißt in herrnhut interessiert
hinter jedem monster soll er den
menschen gesucht haben
während des zweiten weltkrieges nimmt
knittel der mittlerweile in maienfeld
wohnt einladungen zu lesungen nach
deutschland an
dabei kommt es zu unterredungen mit
joseph goebbels das ist tatsache
die treffen mit dem nationalsozialisten
sind allerdings mit dem bundesrat
abgesprochen
dennoch sind viele schweizer der meinung
knittel ist ein verräter spion ein nazi
schrieb er sehr guten freund
heicks nazi-deutschland bahnen im schnee
der ort furore heicks ort vom tod
also ehrlich dem sehr abgeneigt
erhöhen schreibt derzeit an einer
biografie über den umstrittenen
schriftsteller sie die noch dessen witwe
kennengelernt hat ist davon überzeugt
wer missionars sohn wollte im dritten
reich vermitteln wollte mit der kraft
der worte gegen die gewalt ankämpfen
john knittel starb 1970 viele rätsel
gibt es noch zu lösen